kann ich loslegen ein bisschen weiter in
die richtung mich von hinten drauf hast
du ne habe hey leute was knapp
willkommen bei neuen video
heute bin ich wieder nicht hier alleine
vertreten sondern ich habe wieder ein
special gestern start und java
und zwar um wir beide uns für euch heute
überlegt wir stellen euch einfach mal so
sie sitzt zurzeit top-5 gehalten was
heißt geheilt also das versuchen viele 1
umzusetzen so einen typ von instagram
der uns 15 braucht stellt ihr euch vor
ihr könnt ihr mal gucken ob ihr auch
dabei sind aber wollen gar nicht
anfangen direkt an
okay leute ich würde sagen ich fange an
mit tief nummer eins und zwar kennt ihr
diesen typ das sind mal diese leute die
haben so sonja kann unter der jacke ist
ein t shirt und t shirt noch ein t shirt
unter dem t-shirt ausgangsleistung zu
zwei meter lang bis zum boden getroffen
der auf wassereis typs kamera an
ich mache mir bislang aber ist nicht
lang ist noch nicht lange genug oder
china ein bisschen länger noch so ja
noch ein bisschen noch mal länger noch
ein bisschen kann ich nicht genug klagt
nicht lang genug sein so hatte noch ein
bisschen
ich mach das doch kaputt nach die wut
auch so ein bisschen länger ruhig noch
rechtzeitig einfach so und du machst
okay ich mache fotos 3 2 ein kombi nun
zum nächsten interview modelltypen dass
der spiegel
jeder kennt ihn tausend mal gemacht
tausend mal gesehen aber gar nicht mehr
so gehabt auf in zwei mal so wenn ich
ein foto post vom spiegel server macht
es natürlich immer noch die zehntausende
von likes aber das ist 100.000 aber so
generell ist das gar nicht mehr sogar
hält glaube ich deswegen viele machen
jetzt erst auf richtiges model würde ich
auch sagen fischwasser mit das gut aus
der filter bahn gepostet
okay leute kommen wir zu typen nummer
drei und zwar könnt ihr diese mädchen
das es jetzt speziell auf mädchen mit
zwei mädchen ging auf solche raus fotos
machen die stars und dann passiert
folgendes so das mädchen stellt sich
nicht so in zu kamera sondern so mit
meinen arsch ein bisschen sieht dann
wird der apa nach ausgestreckt und dann
macht man rot-weiße so das ist das geht
so oft er dann denke ich mir kann ich
lustig
ein bisschen weiter in die richtung von
hinten drauf hast du okay in die
richtung das nächste modell derjenige
der den photoshop facebook filter etwas
zu viel benutzt da auch nicht seine
grenzen kennt dann kommt irgendwann was
raus dass viele barbiepuppe original
wirklich geile aussicht fünf mal direkt
111 ii
so müsst ihr natürlich keinen bildete
noch niemandem geschadet ein cooler und
poste ich war okay leute kommen wir zum
letzten typ und zwar dass ich in letzter
zeit wirklich so oft das sind so
irgendwelche leute die haben so tausend
follower war instagram und denken so
schon sie sind der übelste fashion
blogger
das kann ich auch richtig gut vorstellen
die schreiben dann diesen shop an diesen
shop von dränglern event wird gesponsert
werden ja ihre quasi die fesche lola ist
echt tolle sache da denke ich der
alpenrand ab den führerschein weil man
schon 1993 bei instagram wir schauen mal
wieder zeit für neuen post aber ich habe
doch gar keine klamotten
da schreibe ich mal die shops an das
können wir dann eben hallo liebes team
ich steck fashion for life betreibe
erfolgreich einen instagram account mit
schon über 1000 voran
wollt ihr mehr nicht die neuen like
jesus zukommen lassen und abgeschickt
die werden bestimmt begeistert sein
ja weil ich soviel erstmal dazu gehört
natürlich jetzt hat euch gefallen und
jetzt auf keinen fall wegschalten ich
wollte euch noch was sagen zweiter
jascha sich jetzt auch ein youtube schon
erstellt da ist auch heute schon das
erste video online gegangen zu sein wie
sonst vögelchen gezwitschert deswegen
schaut aber beweisen
ganz oben im video beschreibung verlinkt
check das ablassen aber da wird mich
persönlich auch sehr freuen
wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder oder
übermorgen keine ahnung ich denke aber
schon morgen vielen dank dass ihr euch
das angeguckt hat und sagt dabei war es
eigentlich ein dufter dafür danke ich
bin heute abonnieren doch nicht